hey guys what's up so today I'm going to
be making you some lego themed candies
this is inspired because I just saw the
Lego Batman movie and it was so good it
was so cute I have seen the original
Lego movie so many times and if you've
seen that then you know how awesome the
Batman character was in that movie
moving this cute premiere was awesome
I'm off to the Lego Batman movie
premiere and I'm bringing some of my
friends I was trying to decide which
ones would make the cut to take with me
on the carpet and I've decided to pick
Batman my vintage Bennie myself Steve
Jobs the Unicorn I guess I should
probably bring em it as well because
he's kind of a big deal the old-school
Princess Leia so I think these are gonna
be the winners you guys think good
choice just needs to be a better set up
because I can't actually see that at all
[Music]
all right so right here on it e they go
Batman black in yellow carpet I've got
my made it pretty exciting
[Music]
three parties going on
telling Emma nice hands
and after some years they had a bunch of
like little cupcakes and they had little
candy
Batman logos and I tried to steal one to
bring home so that I could put it on
this Lego guy's chest but it got a
little crunchy and I didn't think that
was a really good idea to put in my
purse and it would make a mess so I'm
gonna try to just recreate the logo
myself it's probably not gonna work so
maybe I'll just write back in hey honey
so before me I've got some yellow
candies melting and that's gonna be the
body of a horror Lego man he's huge it's
gonna take a lot of candy to go inside
of just body it's also got some little
ones and I'll probably make some cute
little Lego bricks so I'll just uh melt
a few of these up and see what happens
all these are melting up nice they're
set these aside get these melted up yeah
that didn't do anything
oh yeah that's getting somewhere oh yes
look at this is beautiful it's so pretty
I love candy melts they're incredible
and now we're gonna fill up these little
Lego bricks let's our candy notes
[Music]
here take a pic see how these are
melting
oh they're melting really really nicely
these things are so great because it was
like a super consistent melt and it's
just Wow incredible okay so I've been
letting these things melt for a really
long time it looks like you've already
guessed let's put them in here and hope
for the best
the big moment I hope that I have enough
because I'm a little concerned that I
don't have enough yellow and if I don't
not really sure what I'll do I'm not
gonna do anything because it's gonna be
too late he's filling in nicely though I
mean as long as I cover most of it I
think we'll be all right this is a heavy
heavy man get in all of those crevices
bud
get in there wait this is great this is
great oh I'm so happy I thought I was
gonna don't have enough well I guess I'm
just gonna let this sit somewhere
because there's nothing else I can do at
this point I'm gonna just move it aside
cuz this is gonna take a long time to
cool or shall I put it where shall I put
it
oh gosh
oh no that didn't work out so well well
just fill these up I'm done I'm done
trying to be precise and not make a mess
I am done with that there will be no
more precision sick of it I'm sick of
the precision here we go there we go I
tried I tried I got bored and they want
to do it anymore oh that's hot what a
bad idea
what's gonna happen to this my fingers
are burning my fingers are burning
stupid idiot why would you do something
like that
every idea I look forward to seeing what
this looks like I'm gonna let all of
these things cool for the next few hours
or perhaps a day because I don't know
how long it's gonna take so I'll see you
guys back here sometime so it's uh I'm
not even joking it's like a week later
and I've been saving these not because
it took that long to harden but because
I was lazy and I just didn't finish the
rest of the video so what we're gonna do
to make cleanup extremely easy is I'm
gonna put some this isn't what I thought
I ordered I thought I ordered like clear
saran wrap like what the heck is this
press and seal
yeah what is it though has anybody
watched santa clarita diet because
that's what i feel like i'm doing right
now it's basically this family the mom
eats humans spoiler alert this is they
put down the plastic to not make a mess
when they kill the bodies so these were
the first ones that I did they were like
the little Lego bricks
oh yeah that's making a mess this was a
good idea oh boy this is one of those
expectations vs. reality moments
they've all got air bubbles on them
[Music]
every single one looks like trash it's
like Merry Christmas here's nothing
under your tree I forgot about this one
uh this is a mess these ones actually
look better than the bricks and I
wouldn't have been an idiot and just
ruined it at the last minute so I guess
I never really gave you guys a full
review of what I thought was a Lego
Batman movie it was surprisingly really
really good and you know the Batman
character in the original lego movie is
so good
but overall the characters were
incredible they had so many different
references to previous Batman movies
they had somebody throw backs for
parents because clearly the kids were
not around when the original Batman was
so this right here is our big Lego
minifigure and I'm gonna try to draw the
Batman logo on him just to tell you the
whole Batman theme that we've kind of
got going on here
oh boy oh holy crap this is the coolest
thing ever look at this huge candy Lego
man he worked out very very well he is
cool he is super super cool unofficially
licensed bat me a knife I really just
wanted an excuse to use it because this
is doing absolutely nothing really let's
draw the Batman logo on his chest with
an edible food pen I'm not very artistic
I mean I am but like I'm not I'm already
nervous I'm gonna mess it up this is not
working very well
this is like freaking discount Batman on
sale okay don't worry mommy's got a plan
when I went to the premiere I tried to
steal one of these logos off of a
cupcake there was absolutely no way that
I would be able to bring it back
a fingers her
it's not as good as I'd hoped but you
can't hope for the best on your first
try thank you you mean you could hold
but you can expel that I'm gonna happen
cool
I'm super proud of it let me add them to
this massacre of Rick's well anything is
even like a Batman movie let me know
what you think and let me know who your
favorite character is I don't want to
even mention any of the characters
because I want it to be a surprise for
you guys alright that's it I got to
clean up my kill zone here I'll see you
guys my next video bye
we've got mess mess mess mess camera
camera monitors so I can see what's
going on and just more messed just a lot
a lot of mess we've got batteries
charging non-stop yeah this is it
the worst part about cooking videos